ai
could add 16 trillion dollars to the
global economy
in next 10 years this economy is not
going to be built
by billions of people or millions of
factories
but by computers and algorithm we have
already seen
amazing benefits of ai
in simplifying tasks bringing
efficiencies
and improving our lives however
when it comes to fair and equitable
policy decision making
ai has not lived up to its promise
ai is becoming a gatekeeper to the
economy deciding who gets a job
and who gets an access to alone
ai is only reinforcing and accelerating
our bias
at speed and scale with societal
implications
so is ai failing us are we designing
these algorithms to deliver biased and
wrong decisions
as a data scientist i'm here to tell you
it's not the algorithm
but the biased data that's responsible
for these decisions
to make ai possible for humanity and
society
we need a urgent reset instead of
algorithms
we need to focus on the data we're
spending time and money
to scale ai at the expense of designing
and collecting
high quality and contextual data we need
to stop the data
or the bias data that we already have
and focus on
three things data infrastructure
data quality and data literacy
in june of this year we saw embarrassing
bias
in the duke university ai model called
pulse
which enhanced a blurry image
into a recognizable photograph of a
person
this algorithm incorrectly enhanced a
non-white image
into your caucasian image african
american images were
underrepresented in the training set
leading to wrong decisions
and predictions probably this is not the
first time
you have seen an ai misidentify
a black person's image despite an
improved ai
methodology the underrepresentation
of racial and ethnic population still
left us with a biased results
this research is academic however
not all data biases are academic biases
have
real consequences take the 2020 u.s
census
the census is the foundation for many
social
and economic policy decisions therefore
the census is required
to count hundred percent of the
population in the united states
however with the pandemic and the
politics of the citizenship
question under counting on minorities is
a real possibility
i expect significant undercounting of
minority groups
who are hard to locate contact persuade
and interview for the census under
counting
will introduce bias and erode the
quality of our data infrastructure
let's look at under accounts in 2010
census
16 million people were omitted in the
final counts
this is as large as the total population
of arizona
arkansas oklahoma and iowa put together
for that year
we have also seen about a million kids
under age of five under counted in 2010
census
now under counting of minorities
is common in other national census as
minorities
can be harder to reach their mistrust
towards the government
or they live in area under political
unrest
for example the australian census in
2016
under counted aboriginal centaur state
population
by about 17.5 percent we estimate
under counting in 2020 to be much
higher than 2010 and the implications of
this
bias can be massive let's
look at the implications of the census
data
census is the most trusted open
and publicly available rich data on
population composition
and characteristics while businesses
have proprietary information on
consumers
the census bureau reports definitive
public council on age gender ethnicity
race employment family status as well as
geographic distribution
which are foundation of the population
data infrastructure when minorities are
under accounted
ai models supporting public
transportation
housing healthcare insurance are likely
to overlook
the communities that require these
services the most
first step to improving results is to
make that database representative of
age gender ethnicity and raise
personalized data
since census is so important we have to
make every effort to count hundred
percent
investing in this data quality and
accuracy
is essential to making ai possible
not for only few and privileged but for
everyone in the society
most ai systems use the data that's
already available or collected for some
other purposes
because it's convenient and cheap yet
data quality is a discipline
that requires commitment real commitment
this attention to the definition data
collection and measurement of the bias
is not only under appreciated in the
world of speed skill and convenience
is often ignored as part of nielsen data
science team
i went to fill visit to collect data
visiting retail stores
outside shanghai and bangalore the goal
of that visit was to measure
retail sales from those stores we drove
miles outside the city
found these small stores informal hard
to reach
and you may be wondering why are we
interested in these specific stores
we could have selected a store in the
city where the electronic data could be
easily integrated into a data pipeline
cheap convenient and easy why are we so
obsessed
with the quality and accuracy of the
data from this stores
the answer is simple because the data
from these rural stores
matter according to
international labor organization 40
chinese and 65 percent of indians
live in rural areas imagine the bias in
decision when 65
of consumption in india is excluded in
models
meaning the decision will favor the
urban over the rural
without this rural urban context and
signals on livelihood
lifestyle economy and values
retail brands will make wrong
investments on pricing
advertising and marketing or the urban
bias
will lead to wrong rural policy
decisions with regards to health
and other investments wrong decisions
are not the problem with the ai
algorithm
it's a problem of the data that excludes
area intend to measure in the first
place
the data in the context is a priority
not the algorithms
let's look at another example i visited
this remote
trailer park home in oregon state and
new york city apartments
to invite these homes to participate in
nelson panels
panels are statistically representative
sample of homes
that we invite to participate in the
measurement over a period of time
our mission to include everybody in the
measurement
led us to collect data from these
hispanic and african homes
who use over-the-air tv reception to an
antenna
permission data these homes constitute
15 of us households
which is about 45 million people
commitment
and focus on quality means we made every
effort
to collect information from these 15
percent
hard to reach groups why does it matter
this is a sizable group that's very very
important to the marketers brands
as well as the media companies without
the data
the marketers and brand and their models
would not be able to reach these folks
as well as show ads to these very very
important minority populations
and without the ad revenue the
broadcasters such as telemundo
or univision would not be able to
deliver free content
including news media which is so
foundational to our democracy this data
is essential
for businesses and society our
once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to reduce human bias in ai
starts with the data instead of racing
to build
new algorithms my mission is to build a
better data infrastructure
that makes ethical ai possible
i hope you will join me in my mission as
well
thank you